no one signs a record deal and has a
manager come up and go there's a good
chance you're going to be really famous
here's a pamphlet on how to not be
[Music]
money and fame can show you who you are
and one of the things you said is the
person i was when i was 27 was a [ __ ]
monster when i became famous i just went
a bit off the rails with drugs and
alcohol i think there was just this one
weekend at glastonbury where i just kind
of disappeared for 48 hours i was in an
absolute state what was the cost well
it's just not nice to see your parents
cry you know
wow
i look back as it being one of the worst
weeks ever and then i met erin just
watching someone grow a baby and give
birth is like one of the most sobering
experiences ever you tragically had a
miscarriage on your second i remember i
was invited onto lorraine and i was
meant to go on and talk about a single
on a tour just before i went on they
went we just found out you lost the
second baby do you want to make the
whole interview about that
i got so many messages from guys
afterwards just going that was amazing
you went on a spoke about that i've
realized those have been the first times
i've spoken about things that i should
have probably spoken about with friends
or family a long time ago if you were
advising a younger elliot what would you
say in terms of the components that make
for a good life i've often thought about
this
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
one of the things i always try and do
again because i i tend to believe that
we are all a product of our like of
typically our significant childhood
events whatever they might be when i
look at your story i was hazarding a
guess as well i was saying well this was
obviously quite a key moment this is the
key moment but in your own words what
were those
catalyst key moments from your childhood
that ultimately shaped
you to become who you are today
oh wow um
i think
in terms of
work ethic
um it's definitely from my mom and dad i
was very aware as a kid um
you know even
like even before as a teenager how
much time
and effort my mom and dad put into well
like they're both working class and they
both
came from very humble beginnings but i
think the main thing i was aware of is
that
my dad was always away working as a kid
i was also aware that a lot of my
friends parents weren't together you
know there were a lot of them were
raised by just a single mums
um but then i also saw how much effort
my mum put in she was she didn't have a
day job but i could see how hard my mum
worked especially with my dad being away
so i think the work ethic thing
has helped me a great deal in terms of
where i've got to um
par not so much anymore but partly
trying to impress them or
you know feeling like i
lived up to their standards maybe in my
early 20s mid-20s apart from
you know like my parents influence as a
kid
i think mainly i'd say that you know the
culture at school in terms of music
culture london i grew up in fulham i
went to school in wandsworth
and even that was a really nice school
in terms of it was a modern school as a
technology college
as uh i said the majority of kids i went
to school we've all lived on council
estates and
i didn't but i spent a lot of time down
there so i think that was really good in
helping me not only understand
um
different cultures and therefore as a
result where the music cultures came
from
just like
how other people live and how other
people you know what people have to go
go through you know like some of my best
friends their mums would have five jobs
and they'd be living in two bedroom
uh council flats with like seven
siblings
so i think that even though i didn't
live that life it was quite opening to
see that
um
did you enjoy school love school
loved i i loved drama loves maths
i was really good at maths but
not very good at english which is weird
because i use the english language i
manipulate english language for
for financial gain really but um yeah i
wasn't very good at english and wasn't
very good at science because i wasn't
interested in them i wasn't really
interested in
religious studies because i always found
there was occasionally two the different
you know religions whether it's sikh
hindu muslim christian would be like
little squabbles in the playground so i
kind of didn't like that religion could
segregate people
so but everything else i was interested
in geography math drama art
music i excelled at and loved
because you know i loved going to school
my mum was always like
you were an absolute nerd but when it
comes to school you like you couldn't
wait to get there and you couldn't wait
to tell me about everything you'd
learned that day and you couldn't wait
to get there the next day and when it
was coming to the end of school holidays
you couldn't wait to get back to school
so i think i
i enjoyed structure
and i enjoyed either the attention from
being a class clown
at a playground you know playtime
because i wasn't ever very good at sport
i was good at running in a straight line
or swimming in a straight line but i
wasn't good at team sports so i think
um
i
i really felt like
that school was good for not only
my brain which was a bit hyperactive
but also i got this outlet of
doing making people laugh by doing
impressions why did you care about that
making people laugh because i just think
i felt like i don't know i've always
enjoyed being an attention seeker
um my mom said that when i was a you
know very young like five five six years
old
she felt that was a misbehaving a lot at
school and she made a decision to put me
on stage in the local grammar drama
group
i definitely think my mum spotted
something in me which was like this kid
needs to perform and he needs attention
and that's his outlet and that sort of
levels him out a bit i'm surprised to
hear that you were so keen to get back
to school because i also read that you
were at some point bullied by the other
kids yeah i was but i think because
my mum and dad did such a good job and
sort of
i don't i can't i can't even remember
any specific lessons but i just know
that my mom always made me feel loved
and uh
understood you know so if i was
if i'd go home and just be like yeah
they took the piss out on my teeth again
today or they took piss out my ears
again today or whatever
she'd just be like
son we are all built differently
like we were you know she was like your
dad had funny ears when i met him and
he's the most beautiful man in the world
as far as i'm concerned you know just
little lessons like that
so i just think there was so much love
at home
that whatever hit me on the outside
world whether that was down the local
park
you know little kids in gangs or at
school
i just felt like i was mentally prepared
for it
and then i think
that kind of helped it gives you quite a
thick skin in terms of when it comes to
you get into the music business it's
like you have to deal with so much
um disappointment
like when i think that i've been doing
this i'd say
you know i got my first record doing
2006 but i was releasing music in 2004.
um i've played over a thousand gigs you
know like most of my peer group have
disappeared now um from say 2010 2011
when i think of like my peer group from
around then like chasing status and sub
focus are still going
um
but most of the other artists that
i came up with have kind of
disappeared or send me retired or are
kind of just sort of like doing their
own thing on the peripheral now whereas
i'm still very much
my focus is like i'm only competing
myself i used to worry so much about
competing with them
you know mm-hmm
and you got you got diagnosis at a
fairly young age for having asperger's
yeah well yeah but i've been
my mom was quite good and i think she uh
i think
whether it was i don't i can't remember
because i was so young but it would have
ever been from her friends you know
other moms down the park going
elliot's a bit you know on the spectrum
and
you know
what's what's up with him because i was
such a
i suppose like hyperactive kid
and i i'd sort of seem to
flip between different
personalities all the time but i also
had these weird you know weird sort of
like uh nervous twitches
um and i would uh if i had a
photographic memory for like even at a
young age i'd be like just look at a
list of
i know like the american states and just
memorize them very like within two or
three reads
or i'd get
the trivial pursuit box out and memorize
every single question in a box of tribal
pursuit
just so when we came to play with like
neighbors or friends or family at a
barbecue i knew the answer to everything
i think my dad didn't clock that i'd
memorize them all but instead of telling
everyone that i had memorized them all
he was like yeah my son's really really
sharp he's really well you know
um
things like that you know how does that
sit with you now that that diagnosis and
do you still well i just think every
there's no way of knowing who what
anyone is i think everyone can be a
little bit of everything everything it's
not it's not clear-cut to just go this
person is
this diagnosis
based on you know research by doctors
and scientists and other patients it's
very hard because i think every human
being has a little bit of
of something and
you could you can't just say someone is
100 definitely got this yeah you know
that thing
so i prefer i can see some things in my
eldest already
where he shows certain similarities to
me as a kid but
then erin says no i used to do that as a
kid as well
and she's a bit mad like me as well but
i think weird is good
i definitely think weird is good and i
think it's special and i think my mum
spotted that so i'm kind of glad that
i was never put into any special
programs or put into a special school or
extracurricular activities or even on
light medication i'm quite thankful for
that because i've got friends my age
who've been on meds since they were kids
and are still on some form now
you know and they think they're
bipolar or aspergeric or adhd and and
i'm like there's actually a really close
friend of mine who i actually
encouraged him to maybe have like six
months off
and
he uh he's better for it now and he
doesn't take the meds anymore he's like
you know he's better at dealing with his
uh let's say his demons and his
you know these thoughts maybe it used to
haunt him and scare him
he's he stopped taking the meds and he's
he doesn't take him he's back for it
have you have you ever had any of those
demons especially at a young age that
you used to contend with
i think the main thing and i still
contend with it now is sometimes i just
have
so many thoughts
uh
am i i'm not like a warrior i've never
been a warrior because
i've always known how to
compartmentalize stuff and i'm i'm
really good with admin i'm really good
at multitasking
but
i've it's kind of been a gift and a
curse like it's i either been having
a whole say film script or scenario in
my head going round and round
that i can't seem to switch off and that
might be whilst i'm in a meeting i'm not
doing it now
it might be you know like when i say
multitasking i'm like i can sometimes be
in the studio writing a song but have a
shopping list in my head that i just
can't seem to get rid of
um which is why yoga can be really good
for me and like you know breath work
like vim hof style that really levels me
out um
but
for instance like
i
when i'm freestyling
you know like and i don't mean like
pre-written raps that people go out and
perform in a
battle inside i mean like just like
freestyling like rhyming like sometimes
i'll be at the gym
and i'll be there for 45 minutes and the
whole time i'm there i'm freestyling in
my head and it could be about
what that person
is wearing what exercise that person's
doing what music's playing
and it's kind of gift and a curse
because it's great for
you know when you're producing songs
just words being able to just fall out
flow out
but also just like not being able to
switch off sometimes so i'll be in a
room having a conversation with someone
and they're like
you're not listening are you and i'm
really sorry but i've got
a shopping that's right
you're like okay what are you getting
later
and i'm just there like swiss cheese
like swiss cheese
i've just got a very overactive frame
you talked about failure a second ago
you said you know going into the music
industry there's a lot you met with a
lot of failure and ups and downs after
your first album
um your first studio album i was reading
about your kind of your feelings and
sentiments towards it it sounded like
you were gonna quit yeah i think
you have to be prepared for
disappointment
in this industry especially because i'm
about to release my eighth album
and i don't really have any expectations
for it other than whoever hears it i
hope really enjoys it because i don't
really know how many streams it's gonna
do or it's just
you have to be quite robust
in the sense that
you may put so much time and effort into
a song
and radio one or capital turn around and
don't playlist it or
you make a song and think this is going
to perform really well on spotify
because i should get on the workout
playlist
and it will get on the uk house playlist
and maybe this could do well in germany
and like not that i make music like that
but once the song's finished you can't
help but have expectations for it
and then to think that you might have
spent you know i might have written it
in four or five hours but then spent six
months perfecting the mix downs and
adding instrumentation and so on or
adding another vocalist or a feature to
it
and then to think that that might come
out and someone's someone somewhere is
like
nah not actually into this when i was
trying to ministry of sound it was so
much pressure like
you know constant meetings every week i
wouldn't go to them because after a
while they get too intense but it's like
we're ready one uh uh discussing this in
playlist this week we're hopefully gonna
go on the c list next week and then two
weeks later we'll hopefully move up to
the b list and then the aim is weaker
release we're gonna be on the a list and
we should be getting 11 to 15 spins a
week and you know hopefully we'll going
straight into itunes with pre-orders
into the top ten and we'll climb to
number one and mtv are fully behind this
and you're going to do a live lens next
week and capital have just come on board
with it and it's all
you know it's it's great when you're
flying you know and obviously you always
have number one singles and top tens
it's great but
you realize
the pressure that artists are put under
and managers and then the pressure that
the record labels are putting on
themselves
you know to compete
with you know because they've got to
bring in x amount of revenue as you know
if you're in marketing or andr
they're under pressure from your bosses
and then the
artists are under pressure from the
label and then the managers are under
pressure from what the artist expects
and
it's actually a losing formula money and
fame they often say can show you who you
are or it can bring out the
the best and worst in you and one of the
things you said is the person i was when
i was 27 was a [ __ ] monster compared
to the person i was when i was 21.
yeah what did you mean by
[ __ ] monster
i was just um well see so i i hadn't
tried
uh class a drugs until i was 23 which is
mad because most of my
friends and peer group in music and i
grew up with were probably doing it at
14. um
and then i just think when i became
famous
and came into money i just went a bit
off the rails with drugs and alcohol but
i was also in a relationship where i was
lying to my girlfriend and cheating on
her and i was just
everywhere i was going girls were
throwing themselves at me and
people wanted to party with me and
people were doing everything they could
to try and keep me awake all night with
them
you know whether it was girls or bad
influences other celebrities you know
and then you get carried away she's like
oh my god i'm hanging out with such and
such actor and such and such footballer
and
this model and this person and where
we've got access to this bar and this
club and we've walked straight into this
restaurant and got a table so you just
go off the rails a bit and i feel like
everybody kind of needs to when you get
to that stage every artist
actor that i've spoken to whether
they've chipped away it for years like i
did
or just had this sudden overnight fame i
feel like you kind of need to get out
your system because it's kind of like
it's not not saying everyone has to but
nearly everybody i know is just like
oh god how amazing does this feel right
i'm getting free clothes and free
trainers and i've just been giving this
free car i'm getting upgraded on this
flight and i've
got this table this restaurant that i
couldn't get before i've been invited to
this premiere i was just on that
television show with that hollywood
actor
and then i'm in this person's house you
know this person's giving me free drugs
and this girl wants to sleep with me and
this guy these girls want to freeze them
and then all this [ __ ] so
he's like
why would you not take it because you
get to do something that you know it's
like a one in a million thing no one
else gets to do this you don't you don't
go i need to do this because no one else
gets to do it you're just like this is
[ __ ] this is fun this is mad like my
life's mad right now
and i just defy
anyone to not
to not do the same i mean i think
you know sometimes like top level
athletes because
they have to their focus is being an
athlete so it's all about their body and
their fitness
they
can't do drugs and alcohol in the same
way so i think for a lo that's why that
footballers just end up like i'm gonna
have 15 cars or i'm gonna get gambling
addiction
because everyone needs some kind of
vice i guess i mean all human beings
need some kind of vice anyway i think i
think that's how we're built we're not
meant to just live
squeaky clean right constantly like i
think life's boring like
and it doesn't have to be sex or drugs
and alcohol but someone you need
something you need something
to obsess over that feels a little bit
like naughty a little bit edgy
what was the cost
because i mean all that sounds great but
there's got to be everything in life has
a cost well
the cost was i you know i broke a a
lovely girl's heart and
you know
took her a while to deal with that i'm
sure afterwards and
you know i probably upset quite a few
people along the way i know my parents
weren't proud of me even though i was
doing really well
career-wise
um there was like a moment where there
was a bit of an intervention you know it
was almost like what have you become
you know we're not proud of you this is
not cool
what caused that
i just i think there was just this one
weekend at glastonbury where i just kind
of went down with my band and crew and
my girlfriend and my sister and i just
kind of
just completely went off the radar kind
of disappeared for 48 hours
and then everyone was like where is he
and obviously glastonbury's a crazy
place to get lost in anyway and then i
just turned up 15 minutes before i went
on stage so still professional
but
i was like i was uh i was in an absolute
state around like 2012
maybe 2010 to 2012 well it wasn't great
when your family staged an intervention
what does that look like in like real
terms is that like a phone call or is
that well no it's like
sort of catching me off guard and
sitting me down in a
in a room you know and
showing me how disappointed they are
and how did you take that well it's just
not nice to see your parents cry you
know
it's quite
you know it still took me a few years
after that to get my act together
um
but yeah i just
i don't i don't feel like there's any
real shame in it looking back like i'm
not i'm not saying i'm proud of it but
i just feel like
certain mistakes have to be made it's
like in the same way i don't really have
any regrets about anything i'm just like
everything i've ever done in life
however bad it is whoever i've hurt or
whatever i've learned from it and i've
tried to make amends for it you know
did is there in hindsight information
that you didn't have that caused you to
choose that path like is there something
you you now know
that is stopping you from
repeating that cycle and just continuing
to do that well it's just like i mean
like my mum was as a kid she was like i
was i was a liar as a kid but she said
they were like
not really lies that really would hurt
anyone she said i just knew that you had
this overly creative
brain and this imagination so you would
just take situations and just exaggerate
them
and she was like and it kind of makes
sense that you're a songwriter and
you're a storyteller and i get that and
looking back now you never there are
certain times i know it would really
upset my parents and my mum in
particular because she was spending more
time with me probably day to day
you know like 10 like little white lies
about scenarios that had happened just
because i sort of enjoyed the fact maybe
that i would attention seeking could
manipulate a situation that i could
take a situation and my imagination run
wild with it and create other scenarios
and i think that was uh something i
don't do at all anymore but
like lying as a kid and then carrying
that through i didn't then obviously
realize at school you can't get away
with certain things because you know
there's structure and there's teachers
so it probably calmed me down a bit then
and then
i'd had like four serious girlfriends
and i'd never once
cheated on them because it just wasn't
on my radar wasn't the way i've been
brought up
but it's just like
i guess and i've spoken to other
guys about this and girls this is like
you have that
first time you do it
you feel bad and then one becomes two
and then two becomes five and five
becomes ten and then it just kind of
spirals out of control and you kind of
just like numb your brain to it
and i just don't think there's no no one
signs a record deal or gets into the
music industry and has a record label or
a manager come up to them and go by the
way there's a good chance you're going
to be really successful and famous in
the next year or two years
so read this book here's a pamphlet on
how to not be a [ __ ]
people often say that if you are a late
late to lose your virginity
you some
when you get into your adulthood you
kind of make up for lost time well
that's that was me so all my friends
were losing the virginia at 13 and 14
and i was 17 and a half so i was
probably one won the last at my school
maybe it's just a part of south london
but um
yes i used to hear stories from other
other guys at school about some of the
stuff they were doing at 14 and that was
just like absolutely mind blown but i
definitely feel that because i was a
late bloomer then by the time i was in
my like early to late 20s
i just went crazy with it because you're
almost doing it for your younger self
you know yeah
yeah
that was what i was i suspected because
i was reading through and i remember
thinking
yeah if you're a bit of a late bloomer
and then you get it full-on you know
yeah early 20s because you become this
star and it's thrown at you it's always
like
exactly because like some guys at school
like you know the guys who develop a bit
faster than the other guys you know
they've got biceps and six packs at 13
14.
and they're exceptional at football
regardless of what their academics like
or they're the fastest sprinter and then
they're really good looking and then i
went to school with guys who slept with
like 15 girls by the time they were 16.
so chances are they get to the mid to
late 20s and they're not like oh i need
to just go out there and go crazy
because they've already done it whereas
not only did i i didn't feel like i
needed to go crazy but given the
opportunity and you're presented with
like you can
i'm just like a kid in a sweet shop you
know exactly and then like really you're
just like
yeah this isn't me
you know i just become a bit boring and
mundane after a while was there a point
where you you felt that well you thought
you know i'm doing all this but i hate
myself
was that 2000
yeah and then luckily i just and then i
met aaron what was so but
specifically so was that was there days
where you were waking up thinking what
the [ __ ] is my life
yeah
like
it's also it's like you come on stage at
a gig at 11 p.m
in manchester i remember there was this
one week we was just like i look back as
it being
one of the worst weeks ever where
um i was just splitting up properly with
my ex who i cheated on a lot you know
moving out from hers i was pretty lonely
because i was living with my
step-grandad
in like a an ex-council house in fulham
um and he was like
93
and the whole house was like it smelled
quite bad and it was falling apart i
mean his blessing he was in great shape
and for 93 and
but obviously the house wasn't the
cleanest nicest place you could live i
didn't really have much cash even though
i was starting to become quite famous
and successful it was like the money
tends to come six months later you know
you have a number one single or kick
starts with number three in the charts
your festival fees will go up tenfold
but probably not until the following
summer
and so i'm still living with him so it's
quite it's quite embarrassed to bring
friends or even girls back to this place
um so i just moved finally moved out
from
what my ex which has had to happen it
was a long time coming
and then i was like
i was doing a gig in manchester came on
stage at 11
and then i had to be up at 4 30 a.m the
next day to shoot a music video because
we had to catch a catch sunrise
and i was like why can't we do sunset
and pretend it's sunrise you know so i
can actually go home and have a sleep
they're like oh the director can't work
that late or something
and i remember looking
when i look like i've never watched a
music video since it was for a video
called two lives and the lyric is
actually called it's like two lives
living two lives don't know which side
of me is where the truth lies that's the
chorus
um
so it was like a poignant moment
recording a music video for a song on
about three hours sleep i looked awful
in the video like huge bags on my eyes
and then went back from the video shoot
to
this house where my step granddad was
and
just sort of sat in bed feeling quite
lonely
and then the next day doing like a
magazine cover shoot and then going
straight to radio one to record a live
lounge
and then going out for dinner that night
for you know like for a pr press junket
or something and then the next day was
like another tv show and another radio
show
and then
i caught this girl to come around just
because i literally just wanted a cuddle
you know
and then was up there till like 4 a.m
and then up at 8am and then starting a
taxi for like an hour and a half to go
across to that hackney
whole time just you know i remember just
getting to the end of the week just
going like i can't do this
i can't do this right
and i remember saying to my manager i
was just like we need to start
cancelling this tv and radio and it was
just like
you know he's like you can't cancel
going on graham norton
you know you can't cancel going on you
may be canceled no offense probably
cancels going on sunday brunch
sorry sunday brunch
but you just got banned for something
yeah and then and then you're almost
like
when's my next day off
in eight days you know stuff like that
it was like what we've got this weekend
again because i'm at this point wouldn't
look at the diaries it would scare me it
was like well you've got
um i beat the rocks friday and then
you've got global gathering saturday
and then you've got
um something in finland on sunday
and then i was like i've got monday off
no no no
you got majorca and then you've got
ibiza again tuesday
and then you get into each thing and
you're just so
completely knackered
like [ __ ]
that you're just like
okay i have a drink you know i'm
drinking on the plane drinking we get
there and then you kind of remember the
gigs
i remember like you look look at the
photos in the videos you're like the
crowd we're having an amazing time thank
god that i can do this even when i'm at
my lowest when i've got no energy left
when i've had six seven drinks
but i looked back and that was one of
the worst weeks ever and then i think it
was maybe like june
2011
album came i know july and then i went
to australia
in october that year to do my first ever
australian and that's when i met erin
when you're like sort of self-medicating
to kind of deal with the pace of life or
whatever
it tends to be the case i mean just from
sitting here speaking to musicians that
you're not far especially when you like
you use the word lonely with like a lack
of connection you're not far away there
from
mental health issues like anxiety and
depression and those kinds of things
typically when you find yourself without
connection in your life
self-medicating
stressed by just looking at the thought
of this hectic schedule a lack of sleep
i can't imagine the diet was phenomenal
no it wasn't i mean like i i've always
been into fitness and running and i
would like
even when i was really really knackered
like i've got my apartment still in in
fulham right next to craven cottage
and it's actually that that was a big
help because that whole period is like
waking up every day the river gave me so
much
calm
right were you anxious yeah but you just
get up and sit on the balcony and have
like i'll make fried eggs on toast
whatever beans on toast and just look
across the river and i live on the part
of the river where there's no buildings
opposite it's like the barnes wetlands
center so you feel like you're in the
countryside so that's a great escapism
straight away
from london
in general so i feel like when i bought
that
um you know subconsciously i was
probably thinking about this peace and
tranquility escape from whenever i'm
home i'd close the door to my apartment
and i've got the river there but
it was uh
i think i was quite smart and i whenever
i could i would go for a swim or i'd go
for a run because i remember my dad used
to say to me when he was
so when my mum was pregnant with me
my dad was working
as i said two hours up in birmingham so
driving four hours a day
um because it was the only job he could
get at the time he was working for a um
computer services company um nixdorf
siemens group
and he had alopecia as well from stress
his dad was dying
he was pregnant with my mom and he was
training for the marathon
and i think
that you know stress-related alopecia is
quite clear why he lost his hair given
everything the aforementioned things
um
and
but i think running is what saved him
from a very young age like that time
alone and like whenever i go for a run
to this day i don't listen to music i
i that most people go for to listen to
music for fitness whatever that is my
brain escapism and it's either swimming
yoga or running
it's the only time when i can not think
about anything else and whenever i was
anxious or stressed about things that
those are the things that saved me i
actually think that
living by the river
and even if i did it twice a week during
those stressful times just being able to
get up and just go for a four mile jog
i don't know where my head would have
been like if i hadn't got that
like i've been out to go out and do that
and run by specifically by the river not
through a city
with traffic lights and cars
on straight onto the towpath over
hammersmith bridge along the river by
fields over putney bridge back through
bishops park pretty much the area i grew
up in and then also i got to the stage
where i was like i was calling girls up
to come over and it was like
who's going to give the best cuddle and
who's going to stroke me to sleep but
that's where
again not didn't really make a conscious
decision but looking back now it would
be like
i don't just want to have like
meaningless sex i just want to actually
be held
you know bear in mind my mom dad and
sister lived on the other side of the
world by this point they'd moved to
australia
you know didn't have a girlfriend like i
had my mates
you know in my band who would in a way
of traveling with the bands that thing
so i traveled with a dj now but back
then i traveled drums guitar bass and
then five or six crew it's kind of like
a little family on the road so that was
probably better than if i'd been with
just the dj that would have been quite
lonely um but yeah i kind of feel like
my
there was an intelligent emotionally
intelligent part of me i wasn't actually
in tune with
was inviting girls over who were going
to give me the best cuddle and struck me
to sleep so i just felt you know from
that sort of fetal position and felt
loved or felt safe you know what i mean
did you know you were lonely
like in the at the time no i didn't at
all that's what i'm saying but in
hindsight yeah there's so many things
about that whole period where
i was so ambitious and i was so
resilient and i was also despite what i
was putting into my body
all things considered pretty
healthy or i certainly had endurance
um in terms of what i was capable of
mental insurance and physical insurance
so
yeah so i wasn't healthy i mean i was
i just had
endurance tonight stamina and that was
probably from
you know
starting
the whole
uh drugs and alcohol thing way later
than most other people you know like say
23 24
had i started that at 18 like most of my
friends
probably would have burnt out ways
sooner but i was in you know when i
wasn't on tour and i wasn't doing
promotions i was at the gym nearly every
day and i'd go to the gym and then for a
run so i was in pretty good shape to be
able to do all these things and also
performing for 90 minutes on stage
can be like playing a football match and
you know sometimes you plan five
football matches a week
and i would always have a good physio
after i got back you know so every three
or four days i'd have a full body
massage needles
um cupping so on just to
and then i would whenever i could i
would spend a whole day two three days i
know it doesn't sound that much but just
complete detox what what was it that
made you go from being someone who was
dishonest in your relationships and
would would cheat on your partner to
being
honest and committed was there a
catalyst event was it erin was it
i just think when i met erin we just
sort of fell so head over in heels with
each other
within pretty much the first night
um and then she dropped me off at the
airport and she was almost a bit tearful
she was i don't think i'm ever going to
see you again i bet you've got a
girlfriend in every city i was like not
at all
no i've got a few in london
but no i was like you think too highly
of me i haven't got girlfriend ever see
and then she called her mum and her mum
was like i bet he's got a girlfriend
every single she was like no no she goes
honestly i think we're gonna get married
after we spent the night together um
but that was my sort of moment i was
just like reset
go back
to
who
you've always known you were
meant to be you know be the person that
your mom and dad raised which is to be
honest and faithful and
and you were honest with her from the
jump we basically
it it was weird because we got to know
each other a lot over face time
and then she'd come to london for two
weeks and go back to sydney and then i'd
go to australia maybe for a week and
then we'd speak on the phone for three
weeks and then she'd come to london
again for maybe a month
and then i'd go spend christmas in
australia do some festivals but also see
my mom and dad and my sister and spend
time i lived with her and bond there but
because that time becomes so precious
you tell each other absolutely
everything so i think we'd been together
six months and we knew
everything about each other in terms of
uh x's
uh worst fears
you know biggest achievements biggest
wants desires everything sexually all
the partners we've been with like you
just it was almost like speed dating
crash course of like
you know
when you when people are together
generally they'll be intimate with each
other or they'll just laugh and giggle
and
go out for dinner you meet each other's
friends and so on when
you're chatting over facetime it tends
to be more like an interview
you know so you end up over sharing
what has aaron taught you about love
there'll be a lot of people that are
listening to your story and they'll
think maybe i'm in the reckless phase
where i'm i'm sampling all the forbidden
fruit and then it seems quite clear from
your story that you you met this person
and as you said you kind of both changed
each other but what what what advice can
you impart on on someone who's in that
reckless phase
oh and i think if people in a reckless
phase you you either you're like i need
to do this now and i don't know how long
you're going to do that for but people
if you're smart you can work it out i've
got guys i know now who are like
they
that because you know they work in high
intensity high pressured worlds of like
finance and hedge funds
and
i know a lot of guys who want to settle
down
but also on the side want to
continue having these other experiences
with women
and i think they feel that they have a
right to do that now i'm not sure if
that's because of the mentality
of a lot of people that i work in that
world with you know like it's a boys
club
sort of thing and
and that's that's you know that's just
how it is i feel like some of them you
know like there's a lot of guys who like
seem to be happily married with kids
my age a bit older
and seem to have all these other
girlfriends and flings and bits on the
side if you'd eren out another
phase in your life though do you think
it would have worked out do you think so
i met we met at the perfect time that's
why she's just get up with someone like
timing is a key factor yeah she'd been
single for maybe seven weeks and i'd
been single for maybe three months if
you'd met her at say 20
i don't know five i don't think so if i
win a match
two or three years earlier wouldn't have
worked
we met exactly right it was almost like
the stars aligned the universe decided
that we were going to collide at that
moment
mentioned she was a gemini and then you
just mentioned the universe decided are
you at all um
spiritual i wasn't
and i am now did she have a role to play
in that yeah i guess so because you know
i just
i used to just think i was in control of
everything
and i know i was one of those people i
don't believe in luck you make your own
luck because i was kind of what my dad
would instill in me and i've never been
religious and i never used to believe in
zodiacs but then i did used to believe
you know
after i'd uh read some stephen hawking
stuff
and then you start reading books on
lateral thinking and the laws of
attraction and so on
you sort of go oh actually yeah we are
just atoms just bouncing off on
one another just like
because we've got brains and we can make
our own decisions but that doesn't still
mean that we aren't in control of
the energy around us and the energy
around other people and how we collide
and then what things come out of that
um so as soon as i got my head around
that and then
aaron started explaining
the zodiac and when you were born and
what time of day you were born and
you know the the distance between
planets and so on and what moon it was
that day
i used to i guess i didn't have the
patience for it before and then like
she's like explaining actually yeah and
that's why some people have certain
traits and so on i'm not like i'm more
into like
spirituality since um you know i'd start
doing yoga for instance
and meditation you know like two or
three times a week
we'll do a sauna and ice bath put the
kids to bed
we'll do like 10 minutes sauna 2 minutes
ice 10 minutes long and two minutes ice
and then you just come out just feel
like
you know you feel so alive
um
and then the moment you kind of have
kids and you're like oh my god there's
these other human beings that we made
you do get in touch a lot more with your
your spiritual side i think because
you're just like
you know
you could it's like science and
spirituality can go
side by side i think you know i think
the spiritual awareness
of oneself actually comes from having a
greater understanding of science and the
way the universe works in general what
impact does that have on your life yoga
breath work and all that stuff
i think the breath works been incredible
right
so if it doesn't involve like ice or
meditation even i listened to um there's
a guy i know back in brisbane he's got
something called the breath collective
and he gets people in like groups of 20
around to his house clears out all the
sofa out the way and the tv and they all
sit on the floor
on their backs with eyes closed and it's
like
it's that rimhoff style of you know like
um
short breath out like deep breath in
short breath out and then holding your
breath
you know in that moment and you feel all
the physical changes in your body like
i'll do it a couple of nights a week i
did it last night because i wanted to
have a good night's sleep and there's a
lot of stuff going on my head but
like it's hard if you'd tried to sell
that to a younger me i would have been
like you're having a [ __ ] laugh you
want me to spend 10 minutes of my day
breathing in and out in silence what you
because i just didn't understand how to
relax and how to be at peace with myself
and how to actually deal with my inner
thoughts and inner demons you know how
much credit does aaron deserve for this
um
a huge amount really she's um
just watching
someone grow a baby and
give birth and then breastfeed them for
a year
it's like one of the most sobering
experiences ever
you know
it's like it just blows your mind like
i just think the moment
the rush
of adrenaline endorphins whatever that i
got when
she gave birth to our first
standing up
standing up yeah she'd been training the
whole way through her pregnancy as well
like she found a form of uh
pregnancy hit training which had been
approved by her
midwife and
gp
obviously not crazy jumping around but
you know squats and lunges and
and so on and push-ups obviously not
much ab work
but she was reading lots of um
research saying you know the the
healthier the mother is
you know
yeah it's like if you eat nuts during
the pregnancy
child has no chance of having a nut
allergy
but if the mother eats enough nuts
during it um likewise if she gets her
heart rate up to a safe level that baby
would be born with a
less likely to have a heart condition
and there's other research shows that if
the mother does the x amount of training
throughout you know it's even goes back
to say the hunter gatherer period where
a female might have to be on the move
constantly or on the run
whilst holding a baby
and what that instills in the baby's
genetic makeup when they're born like
you know is
i'd have to find the research papers but
there's
stuff that she was reading about your
baby will have zero chance of asthma if
you do x amount of exercise whilst
you're growing that baby and
it can all be passed on like the science
behind it's mental it's like
when uh like your baby has a way higher
chance of starting life with a better
immune system just from breastfeeding
alone if you admire the camp recipe
because
the baby's saliva
passes information to the nipple
and then the nipple tells the mother
what to put more of into
christ the milk so
it'll be like if the baby's lacking in
iron or zinc
or certain vitamins hits the saliva from
the baby's mouth will tell that to the
nipple and then the mother will produce
milk with more zinc more magnesium more
vitamin d
to to give the baby so which is why a
lot of babies have better immune systems
when
they're breastfed
and not bottle-fed
so just you know on formula so crazy
stuff like that
but then yeah just seeing my wife like
and she had no gas no epidural no
no assistance no you know drugs as it
were to help her through pain relief and
she gave birth standing up and like the
midwife was like catch your baby
who who called it you caught it
no she did and i was and then she just
sort of collapsed into my legs and we
just sat there and then
didn't even look at see if it was a boy
or a girl for like the first 10 minutes
we were just so in awe it was like this
whole it's the most alive i've ever felt
it's mental
and like because apparently the um
the tailbone actually blocks the baby's
head from coming out so human beings
women should give birth on all fours or
standing up they're not meant to give
birth on their backs
because where the tailbone comes up
under the baby's head strikes come on
yeah
women should be standing up so that tail
burns like disengaged and can baby can
basically just fall straight out
mad right yeah crazy i bet you weren't
expecting this today no i wasn't but
there you go every day's a school day
you so you give birth to your foot and
one of the things that i read about was
you tragically had a miscarriage in your
second yeah the second one i think we
got so
i might say cocky so we're so excited
and the first one seems to go so well
um everything from when she found out
she was pregnant to
given birth
that you're not meant to tell people
that early on but then she found out she
was pregnant with the second one that we
lost it was only been five weeks and
really meant to wait
quite a bit longer and have your first
scan and so on
we went around told everyone
and then she lost it a few few weeks
later just before you know like the safe
date
so that was pretty pretty tough i
remember i was invited onto lorraine
kelly show
and i was meant to go on and talk about
a single on a tour and then they kind of
blindsided me and it was just before i
went on they went we just found out you
lost the second wave do you want to make
the whole interview about that
and i was like
for what reason they were just like
because we've never had a
guy come on here and talk about it
before it's definitely not like a
celebrity
i was like okay cool
so that wouldn't be about that and it
was actually it was quite positive
because
i got so many messages from guys
afterwards just going that's amazing you
went on and spoke about that because
guys are just like woman's just lost a
baby
guys just got to get on with it and deal
with it by themselves just do everything
they can to support the mother what was
it like for you well it's really tough
because you just don't know how to
you're like oh my god this is actually
something that was living inside of her
that
has now died and i've just got to be
there for her and i'm just gonna have to
like suck it up and get on with it
because no one ever really asks the dad
how are you feeling how are you feeling
it's not in really in our
in our society it's not
normal everyone just goes oh my god how
is she how are you feeling
just like just helpless really
it's awful
but yeah aaron's my um dad was great and
my dad was great as well
in terms of uh
you know how do you feel how do you
think you should feel how do you want to
feel how did you what do you think you
need to do to get through this
especially when you've already
got a baby and then you're just like how
beautiful that whole experience was and
you're like i could have another one and
then you start
is this gonna happen with the next one
the next one
yeah tough
yeah men don't i mean all of the even
like men aren't really even taught how
to deal with how they're feeling
themselves right like i i i've
actually you know doing stuff like this
and doing interviews with either
magazines or television shows i've
realized there's been sometimes been
first times i've spoken about things
that i should have probably spoken about
with friends or family
a long time ago
you know because we're just
you know it's either the whole macho
thing of you don't talk about that
you know just get on with it
like that's a woman's thing you know
when women discuss things like i'm not
even talking about miscarriages i'm
talking about relationships or
you know
it's one of the most amazing things in
my life that i get to do a podcast which
of course needs money to to fuel and i
have a sponsor like your who i genuinely
believe is going to help every single
person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it does all of that in a
small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me
this ready to drink is the absolute
saviour of my diet throughout the week
where i'm moving at such pace if you
haven't tried you'll give it a try and
if you do
tag me
when you look forward at your future
then so you've got this eighth studio
album coming out
what what
what do you want the next five ten years
to look like in terms of your career
i would love to
accidentally somehow have a chart hit
again just to remember what it feels
like
interesting yeah it's not key to me but
it'll be amazing to have like a number
number one album or a top 10 single you
know it'll probably be based on streams
rather than sales in this day and age
but you know some some
just because i want to remember how it
feels you've forgotten yeah i've
forgotten what it kind of feels like
it's 10 years ago you know i had
like 22 top 40 singles
um i think seven
top tens two number ones
but i haven't anything for so long but
i'm still going like my my tour sells
out in a way that you would assume that
i was still having hits but then you
realize that hits aren't that important
what's important for me is just making
songs that
go off when you perform live you know so
you know i did an hour on saturday night
there were probably seven hits in there
the other
uh nine songs
weren't hits but they still
go off like their hits people majority
of the crowd know them word for words
the energy is there you know the build
the drop
i did the last
sold out tour in the uk
of any artist before covet
which was uh
march
2020.
i played
uh kentish town forum sold out
march the seventh i was back in
australia by ninth i think ten days
later we went into lockdown in brisbane
and the rest of the uk and the world
followed pretty much like april that
year
so i played the last ever tour
and then i played the first
festival anywhere in the world
after covert i mean covered with
everyone was in lockdown in england
america and so on
i played up in darwin in the northern
territory in australia i played 5 000
people they had 23 covered cases
so as long as you go out of a negative
test so i was at a festival in october
october 2021
uh no october 2020
um playing the game diamond five
thousand people and then i came back and
just did my january february tour so i
had one the first sold out to us after
covert so
i feel like live music and my
performance is like my bread and butter
it's what i know best that's what i do
best
but it would be really nice to
you know taste a little bit of success
again with a
with a song that maybe like because it's
still don't forget
i'm still in a situation where i've got
40 gigs this summer anyone who follows
me on instagram is like wow amazing
you're having the best year forever
forever but i still bump into people in
the street and it's like a taxi driver
on the way here today it's like an
example wouldn't ya there you go what
you've been doing you haven't released
any music for years i thought well
released an album in june i did release
another album last year and how does
that feel it's quite it just makes you
just
goes to show you that
there's
there's some people think if you're not
on jonathan ross
or graham norton or on capital fm or on
radio one and you're not playing radio
once big weekend or doing capital
summertime ball
then you've retired and then there's
another bunch of people who hear you in
the clubs or listen to you on spotify
playlist and have no idea even what
radio one or capital fm is
and
then there's your die hards you follow
you'll know every move you're doing from
your instagram but you know i don't
tweet that much anymore because it
becomes quite toxic place but
you know the you meet people and they're
just like i didn't even know you were
playing like well you know you'll be
like they're like oh man what you're
doing in newcastle you're like i'm
playing newcastle academy tonight
they're like but as follows on twitter
i've not seen anything
you know because i used to be known for
tweeting quite a lot back around 2011
and 12 i used to get into a lot of
trouble and have arguments and such and
there but you realize that everyone has
their way of discovering and digesting
and discovering you know discovering
music
um the same way we do with films and so
on or how you read about some people
just read bbc sport some people just
follow a twitter account that updates
you on the premier league and there's
some people who only find out about
music from spotify and there's some
people who still only religiously listen
to the capsule breakfast show every
morning
and the thing that i find is i just have
to know where my fans are and what they
want there's always going to be that
group of people though that if you're
not in the charts they think that you've
either retired or fought exactly and
they still think that's the case for me
so i'll be like even when i got a taxi
to brixton in
february
because i'd like to get black taxis
mainly because my one of my cup my
cousin's a black cab driver i need your
car mike you can't use uber
um i like the tube but whilst i'm blonde
which is for the foreseeable future the
tube's not a safe place for me at the
moment um it's a selfie central
um and then obviously you have one or
two and then that leads to 10 more and
20 more and i don't mind meeting the
general public i love it but it also
it's nice to just sit on a tube and
listen to music sometimes rather than
having constant photos but this guy was
like so what you doing were you guys
there gig plans and i was like yeah it's
my gig
he's like oh whoa i'm driving examples
who's on gig i was like yeah i'm you're
taking me to soundcheck now you went ah
sworn you retired you're like my eldest
used to come watch you does that piss
you off a bit
yeah because i'm like when they're like
my eldest used to watch you know i'm
like well if you just follow me on
instagram you can still keep up to date
with my song releases and he can still
come what anyway i ended up putting all
three of his kids and their partners on
the guest list
and then i got a dm i think from one of
his sons the next day i think someone
was maybe 26. it was a hard time in my
life reminding me so you've just
realized that because you're not on
capital fm anymore
that certain people if like i don't know
they could be a decorator they could be
an estate agent they could be a
you know a taxi driver whatever but
everyone has their go-to places for
music and it might be like
in your office where you work all day on
they have radio one on so whatever is on
radio one may dictate which festivals
they go to or who they go and see on
tour because it's advertised on there
it's like you know like playing at v
festival playing at cream fields is blah
blah blah blah
but if you're not if other people only
discover music from their spinning class
and whatever music's playing so people
message me go oh your new single was on
my spinning class today i didn't even
realize you were still releasing music
and you almost want to go well i've
released three albums
since then and you know 11 singles but
you can't it is quite frustrating was
that you left you kind of left the
when you with those labels and you were
charting all the time with these with
these these like big global hits you
leave that
game and then it was there a moment
where it was difficult to deal with the
what you've described there where it was
most difficult to deal with it where
people are going where are you like
where's where's the music like why
aren't you charting if you fall well it
is you know what also is really
frustrating is right so
i've performed in 27 countries in europe
um i'd say about 10 of those countries
i've i've headlined festivals so there
was a period where i was really big in
finland hungary estonia
uh czech
slovenia slovakia latvia lithuania i'll
be doing one or two festivals in those
countries every year for four or five
years
headlining or second on the bill really
really decent fees
and then you i left ministry of sound
um
2013 signs of sony
didn't really haven't had no success at
sony and he had one top 10 single album
bombed they spent a fortune on it didn't
really know where to position me and all
of a sudden all the gigs dried up in
these countries as well
and
we were going back to them like with
spotify numbers and you know saying well
he's still got you know four percent of
his fans uh are in hungary which is
massive considering my fan base in the
uk and australia is my second biggest
like four percent in hungary
and then it would be like you know one
percent of his listeners are poland
that's a pretty big listenership still
and then it was like 2.8 of his
listenership in colombia and you go to
these promoters and they'll just be like
look his last single that 10 of his
listeners came from your country and
they're almost like yeah but it's not
radio and you're like radio [ __ ] debt
you know
or you know i've been and done a chat
show in germany for a bit so i'm not
getting i played
the biggest festival in germany it's
called rockham ring and rockin park so
that's like their reading and leeds i
played that festival three times
unbelievable massive cars i knew the
words word for word like half my set
i had three top ten singles in germany
and then the moment you're not on radio
they're like no i would like to book him
but there's until he gets back on the
radio and you're like well they know my
other hits and like and there's people
streaming the new stuff
so this summer we got we've got bennet
kasim in spain
um we've got a gig to lend off in
portugal and i'm playing amsterdam this
friday
um but it's been really tough like to
actually go in and like almost having to
present the figures
i see this with artists that have that
meteoric i mean i sat with craig david
and he's an example of an artist at 18
years old i think he had a number one
album something [ __ ] staggering and
he's only like a year older than me but
in my mind craig dave was like five or
six years he was in the charts at the
same age as i was listening to so i was
in clubs listening to garage music yeah
yeah exactly and he was on top of the
pops yeah i didn't have any success
until eight years after that so i was 26
27.
yeah and there's a 22-year gap between
yeah when craig david i think had his
first one to his his most recent album
is there a thing of like
you basically start competing with a
former version of your success you have
to i only compete with myself
but and when i'm in the studio i'm only
competing myself but the form of the
yeah and my former first which is why i
say to you i'm
over the moon that i've got my busiest
summer in six years
um i'm i'm i'm
so in love with this album i'm still
playing this album but even though it's
been finished for months um
but that's why i'm like i'd love to just
taste that
chart success again just once or twice
a to shut up all the people who think
i'm retired
and b just to remember what it feels
like you know it's almost like a little
validation that my career is going to
continue for next five six seven eight
years as long as i stay fit and healthy
and i keep producing music and people
still want to come and you know they
choose one night a year they go out to a
gig
10 of their mates get absolutely off
their face and have the time in life if
they i want them to pick me for that
then i've got a career i don't need
anything else i don't need radio i don't
even really need streaming
um
but it would just be nice to have that
validation and i shouldn't reset it
again i need validation but it would be
really nice to fill that again so every
time i get a taxi it's like oh you shot
whoa i heard you i'll see you on
jonathan ross the other day i thought
you'd given up you know as australia
rather than just sitting there going
i've never stopped releasing music i've
never stopped touring but i've been
touring for 16 years i've been releasing
music for 16 years but
you know what i mean no slightly
frustrating but
i think this about myself and when
you're talking about having this kind of
chasing the the former version of
yourself i worry about that sometimes i
think i always think especially now that
i'm on
dragon's den on the bbc i think when i
come off that the cabbie who watches bbc
one but doesn't have a clue about
podcasting yeah yeah yeah is it gonna
happen well you have some people you're
oh you're the podcast guy and there's
everybody it's an age thing for me
someone's coming up to me in the street
i i know exactly where they know me from
by the by their demographic and if if a
56 year old male comes up to me
oh you're on dragon stone yeah he has no
idea that i do anything else or that you
know so so in saying that right so on my
last tour
most nights i come out after our stage
before i get the tour bus and
you know my two minutes will be out and
they'll be like well you'll be out in
about an hour if you want to wear it i
know it's cold put a hoodie on you know
like he makes sure that
you know i say just go and give him a
load of uh monster munch or whatever you
know so he goes out with a big
whatever's left on our rider monster
much maybe a couple of beers he checks
their age and
so some you might have 200 people
waiting after the gig and then by the
time i come out 11 30 12 there might
only be 20. but i'll always say to them
where did you buy this ticket from and
why did you buy this ticket it just does
a little bit of market research and all
the young kids are like we saw
advertisers on your instagram and pretty
much anyone over 30 40 years old they
saw a
billboard a billboard yeah on a bus stop
or on a train station
or their friend forwarded them a link
from gigs and tours or bands in town on
facebook so even though i'm not on bands
in town i don't go on facebook much i
don't really decide when my posters are
put up that's like uh you know the
touring company the promotions company
decided that as long as these people
know where to find me that's great
and then they come to the gig and then
maybe there's like four or five songs
they haven't heard that i've released in
the last two years but chances are the
two of them they'll fall in love with
and go back and continue to stream those
songs or they add it to their playlist
there's an ether to trying to detach a
little bit from
the external validation driving your
self opinion i guess because
as much as it can be like a good driver
of ambition and competition and having
something to aim for is great you don't
want to be dragged like because because
i can see how an artist who is used to
getting number ones all the time could
get a number two and feel like [ __ ]
because yeah it's a number two
whereas really without all the number
ones number two is unbelievable yeah i
was like saying this earlier these these
here are my top tens yeah all of those
those are my three number twos that was
actually unorthodox with wretch yeah
yeah that was will we come back with
calvin
and that would say nothing which came
out just after that and even looking
back it's just like like to go from six
to three from two to one it would have
been nice if those last two just went
one one one like the difference you know
like the difference between that one and
number one was about
267 downloads on itunes and the
difference between that one that one was
maybe like 400 in something and it's
like i know it's nice to say it's
amazing so i've had two number one
singles and a number one album
um
out of everything that i've done in my
career but it'd be extra nice just i've
had four number ones you know i mean but
that's exactly what i mean it's you're
never going to be
but i don't know sleep over it what can
you tell me about this album can i
like listen to something i want to i
need some kind of flavor of this this
eighth album um there's i've never done
drama bass before
and there's two drama bass tracks on it
okay uh
i've i used to when i started emceeing
like 15 it was mainly over uk garage or
garage garage um and the 10 tracks on
this album are garage
and then there's three drill tracks um
with probably the best spitting i've
ever done there's like i'll play you a
song afterwards but there's a track but
i'm just spitting straight for three
minutes
uh we shot the first half of the video
in a shipping container yard in brisbane
which being brisbane we got to use for
free
complete no regulations just like you
might uh open the gate for you we'll be
back at eight please go where you want
just don't don't don't break a leg or
anything done anything stupid um so we
shot this video which i directed in a
container yard and one of my mates who's
in construction we shot the second half
of the video
on the roof of his new apartment block
where i'm standing on top of the lift
shaft and then we've got drone footage
going around me
um
very cost effective video and it's
basically just me rapping solidly for
three minutes and i think it's probably
the best rap and spitting i've ever done
i based it all on buster rhymes but i
used you know from back when i was like
17.
so i'm just hoping won't know that when
people
hear this album
they're gonna go
[ __ ] he sounds
he sounds good he sounds comfortable he
sounds the
most confident
best
performances i've ever heard him do i
truly believe that
and i can't wait for people to hear it
because it's also like you associate
drill music
with uh gangs and
knife crime and
selling drugs and i've basically just
taken inspiration from the beats
um and just done
elliot you know i'm being true to myself
i'm not
which is what i've always done it's just
like i used to feel like i started
saying she was just off air before i
used to feel like i was this uninvited
guest to rap and hip-hop because
i felt that you needed certain
credentials you know to do it
and then you slowly realized that no
it's just like an art form as long as
you're respectful of the culture it's
just like what are you doing with that
that music what what story are you
telling and you've always just got to
tell your own story i guess
having been through all of this
eliot if i really call you elliot having
been through the fame the you know the
ups and downs of the music industry the
you know the sex the drugs the rock and
roll all of it and also the family the
kids and all of that
if you were advising a younger elliot
who might be listening to this and what
actually matters
in terms of the components that make for
a good life what would you say now in
hindsight having tasted it all
right now i mean
like being a dad is so so important to
me and so rewarding especially once
the little one enyo who's now four he
was a bit later with a speech the fact
he can now speak
it's like my young my eldest evander he
was speaking
like
18 months he was saying words and then
our our youngest didn't really start
speaking she was three
but now it's not only just being able to
communicate with them but then listen to
them speak to each other there's bonkers
stuff that comes out their mouth
it's just like it's the most rewarding
thing of the day but i'll spend most of
the day just writing down quotes they've
said and send them to my mum and dads or
my sister or to erin's family just like
you won't believe and
like the stuff that comes out their
mouth that's that's right for me it's
like i love cooking i love food i love
fine dining i love eating out like food
is so important to me training is so
important to me sleep is important to me
sex is important to me being a dad is
important to me
and
if i'm being totally honest like i make
music for a living but i could right now
i love being on stage but if it was that
someone was like you've got another year
now you're not going to write one song
or do another gig i'd be totally happy
with that as long as i had all the other
things
we have a we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest writes
the question for the next guest okay and
i
i read it now so i haven't seen this
before um it says
of all the achievements in your life
which do you think made the biggest
impact on
another
on another
i'm going to guess they mean
also everything you've achieved another
person yes of all the achievements in
your life which do you think made the
biggest impact on another person
um
that's interesting it's a really good
question two minutes in your life which
one do you mean
that is a really interesting question
well do you know what
what i would say actually and i could
probably apply this to a few
[Music]
i'll apply it to two people rather than
just one person in particular
is
there's a guy
three three three people in particular
so there was a guy called david stewart
who was my guitarist for three and a
half years
um
very different to me as like a private
school educated
um but
and and you know grew up
in for in money if you like near near
westbourne grove
and we used to rip him quite a bit he
was like six seven years younger than
all of us
but he was a great kid really good
guitarist really good uh keyboard player
great singer good looking he always
wanted to make it as a solo artist
and for whatever reason this was around
the same time ed sheeran started blowing
up where it's like you could be the best
looking kid in the world but
you know no offense that's a really good
mate of mine but you know what i mean
ed's not a model um he's not that justin
timberlake cut but david fair play to
him like we spent a lot of time writing
songs together i would try and hone his
lyrics he was amazing with melody
and he's now
officially the most successful
songwriter in the world in terms of
streams so he wrote
uh the last three jonas brothers singles
and he wrote uh dynamite for bts which
is wow i think the third or fourth most
stream song of all time it was the most
stream song of the last year
i'm not saying he owes that to me but
what i'm saying is
i know for a fact that his years on the
road with me and the time me writing
songs with him
was instrumental in
his drive and ambition and his craft i
feel like he may have gone on to do this
anyway
but he
you know he
he definitely i feel like success
he's more success and i'm really proud
of him like that he's now the most
successful songwriter in the world
you know and then there's like my
guitarist replaced him another guy
called kai kai he's going to be very
successful composer he went left me to
go and play guitar with jura lipper for
a few years when she was blown up i
might drop my drummer
he was playing with the streets and lily
allen and played with me for five years
he went on to help put together ed
sheeran's live show and create the
technology behind his loot pedals oh
yeah yeah and then my playback guy he's
the guy who runs the laptops which run
alongside the live musicians
he's gone on to put together huge shows
for kygo in las vegas so
i feel like
nearly everybody who's worked alongside
with me i've learnt from them and then
but they've
i guess what i'm saying is i'm glad that
they've all
gone on to do huge things they haven't
gone on to just be standard session
musicians
you know like
my bass player andy sheldrake's now
a producer in his own right he produced
all night so that song was just me and
him you know so my
biggest song i suppose from the second
year of my career was down to him like
everybody there's not one person i've
worked with
closely
in a musical level you know in terms of
what people regard as session musicians
most session musicians just go on to
play for other bands on the road for
eternity you know earning 3 400 pounds a
gig
and they're playing into their 50s or
60s just getting by whereas
all the guys who've been part of my band
who basically my brothers onto my family
or been made an incredible successor
themselves
that's dope and i mean that's that that
says a lot about the environment that
you guys have together when you're
together and like i'm quite proud of
that you know yeah
yeah because i didn't try i didn't
intend to do that it was just obviously
it was clearly a nice place to
work and was inspirational and was very
creative and
ambitious and they've parted company
with me
all on good terms and have gone i'm not
just going to sit back i'm just going to
go and do what elliot's done in my own
way and in david stewart's case it's
like
stratospheric you know but produced and
wrote the biggest song in the world that
year for a korean pop band
mental mad
elliot example thank you hey thanks for
having me i've loved this yeah i mean
these conversations are also so
unbelievably different but i think your
honesty and like there's a real
sort of overwhelming sense of
inspiration i get from watching a man go
on a journey and change in so many
really fundamental ways in terms of
their character their craft their art
and even like their emotional awareness
and their ability to like be in touch
with their emotions tends to be the case
that women can be the catalyst certainly
for me it was you meet the right you're
very easy to speak to though i must say
you're
a real sense of safety and i can talk
about whatever i want and there's no
agenda which is really interesting yeah
because you know it's funny because i
write these questions down that i
actually don't write any questions down
but i write like bullet points things to
remember
and then i genuinely go in the direction
that that i i'm interested in but so
many things you talk about even from
breath work my my girlfriend is a
breathwork practitioner so i'm doing
breath work all the time these days you
know the wim hof thing we've just booked
a retreat to do wim hof's ice thing um
so i had no idea about any of this yeah
exactly so that's why like when you're
saying that i find it really intriguing
to like probing around there yeah um but
it's all led by curiosity and there's so
much in your story that is
really really inspiring to me and i'm
actually the most inspiring thing for me
is what happens next so the most
inspiring thing to me is seeing how your
eighth album plays out how you continue
to like
move with the changing times and
changing platforms and who that that
creative and artist becomes but yeah
thank you for your time today i love
these conversations and it's been super
energizing for me right now will be
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery i think i've worn this piece
for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed colour
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 quid i'm not the
type of person that has rolexes or
jewelry that cost tens of thousands of
pounds i want pieces that are reliable
that look beautiful
and that holds meaning and significance
for me and that's exactly why i've worn
crafted for so long and when we had the
conversation about them sponsoring this
podcast i was so unbelievably keen for
them to do so check it out if you're a
guy crafted london.com and yeah if you
get any pieces of crafted tag me let me
know what you think
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]